Did I scare you?
Welcome in.
Hello.
Wait a second.
It's probably fine.
Hello.
Welcome.
Sorry.
I...
I started the game.
Obviously, to make sure was good and there was a cutscene
that i that i could not pause or anything so we're starting
with no screen so terrified right now hello hello hello me
though how are you doing i'm doing great how are you guys
doing i got my tea i got my um nothing else much actually
i've got my tea and that's about it Oh, hello, Minto, and I
feel like you!
Another day of Minto, and another day of not spilling paint.
It has been so...
It has been months, Colmo.
How often are you painting?
That you are spilling paint so much.
There's got to be somebody.
Somebody on this planet Earth has spilled paint today.
It is...
It's my job.
That makes way more sense.
Minto's serious question.
you got a GamerSupps code, and I need to verify if it's
true, because they're doing a bleach collab, and I'm going
all in, sinister, it is true!
I have a GamerSupps code!
Please use GamerSupps Code Boomer!
If you would like to partake in the GamerSupps Bleach
collab, Boomer, Boomer, Boomer, easy to remember, easy,
easy, easy, Boomer, Boomer, Boomer.
Thank you!
Oh my gosh, if you use my code, thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you, thank you thank you um i can't believe
it though bleach in like 2026 i know there's been like more
bleach stuff like there was like that burn the witch series
or something um i've never been a huge bleach fan but um my
friend she was super into it so she was very very excited so
yeah i can't help thinking drinks company collabing with
bleach is an accident no bleach anime not bleach cleaning
substance i'm so excited to dance the grim fanned meadow i
hope you will enjoy this game by faye julepi i remember you
asking me about playing this so many people have requested
me to play this game so um i'm very excited to try it out jp
thank you dearest minkia i hope this letter finds you well i
am writing to you to inform you that you are goofy silly and
i really admire that oh dearest dearest jb i i also hope
this letter finds you well the weather is quite scorching
these summer days but my heart is a cold hellscape um i
regret to inform you that silliness is off the menu yours
truly mint phantom Thank you so much for the five gifted.
Thank you, wait, I missed another gifted.
And Dragos!
I didn't recognize your profile picture.
You changed it.
Thank you for the five gifted.
You scared me.
We are out of silliness.
Though we have reached thresholds of silliness before that
we cannot ever reach again, and therefore silliness is off
the menu.
oh this is not a silliness actually um i have i apologize i
haven't been able i'm not gonna yapp for too long because i
do want to play the game today um because i have other
things to do so i'd like to play as much as long as much as
long as i can so that i can finish things that i need to get
finished after stream but uh i'm sorry i have not been able
to put out a schedule yet this week um my brain is half
catching up with all the things that i've missed while i've
been uh to use my computer and unable to have a proper setup
and uh also i just don't know what to do i'm just tired i'm
just tired but i'm sick of boxes i'm sick of boxes but i can
say friday or saturday friday or saturday will be well
actually saturday will have two announcements which are kind
of well no sorry an announcement that's kind of cool but
what i'm trying to say is i will have an announcement one of
those days a good announcement exciting announcement so i'm
just saying it early here so that you guys know yes wait is
friday or so oh saturday is july 4th no way but yeah on the
subject of point and click games you might like an old seer
game called slater and charlie go camping with dinosaurs and
shenanigans oh man point and click is so awesome right
pre-announcement yeah this is my announcement of the
announcement because um i haven't been able to put out a
schedule i should i will try and put one out tomorrow though
just to have something even though it's a little late so
sorry so
It may not come as a surprise, but this game was incredibly
formative for me.
No kidding.
It's the only game script I can recite more encyclopedically
than MGS3.
Thank you for playing it.
I hope it's the in-strike your heart as they did mine.
Tom, thank you!
Thank you for the pink.
I was reading...
Wait, hold on.
I have them.
Wait.
With the dogen you gave me, the letters that you both gave
me.
I was reading them just the other day and i was like ah so
thank you mint making announcement of the announcement a
mint wait mint wait well you can you wait uh uh hold on um i
heard you like mints so we put an announcement in your
announcement I also have an announcement for Saturday I'll
be on annual leave for work and we'll be excited about the
announcement by Mim Phantom it might be Friday it might so
don't make the angry YouTube face don't make the angry red
YouTube face it makes me laugh too much mine is too good one
it's my Stop!
It's my favorite.
It's so funny.
I love Mickey Hill Adventure Game Streams.
Not much to say.
Just hope you have a great relaxing stream.
We don't.
Thank you for snoring.
Thank you.
That reference was already dated when I used it in Steinskid
subtitles 10 years ago.
Go away.
You mint it?
I mint it.
I always mint it.
I wanted to let you know I blew locked in and bought out a
time slot to come see you at the Hawkeye Made Cafe today.
I'm so excited.
Wait, I'm so excited to see it.
Holy woomy.
It's not woomy.
It's woomy.
Happy Born's day.
Happy Bappy.
I feel so old and ancient.
Can you sing happy Bappy to make my ancient soul feel
better?
Happy birthday to you, happy birthday to you, happy birthday
to holy woman, not woman, happy birthday to you, happy
birthday to you, happy birthday, happy birthday, happy,
happy, happy, happy, happy, happy, happy, happy, happy,
happy, happy, happy, happy, happy, thank you, thank you,
thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank
you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you,
you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you so much for
six months, shall we get into the game shall we hop right
into the game i'm excited to be a little skilly man
i guess minto got through mystery of the druids that's way
more obtuse than anything in grim fandango is that a little
obtuse oh i will i will try to do my best if i ask for hints
from the team from from the chat then we shall do that yeah
minto i turned 22 today and caught a stream on my birthday
everyone!
It's B Lackey!
Happy birthday!
One more time!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Bougie!
Happy birthday!
Yeah we might have to consult the game for actually.
or something.
We'll see, we'll see, we'll see.
But I do want to start getting into the game so that we have
lots and lots of time to play it.
Don't feel bad about using a guide.
Aw, thanks, guys.
Whoa.
Is that going to appear?
Okay, there it is.
I have it set to the remaster graphics.
Sorry for the wait, Mr. Flores.
I am ready to take you now.
Take me?
Take me where?
No, no.
To the farm, upstate.
Nervous?
No.
Just your appearance.
It's a little intimidating.
Intimidating me.
But I'm your friend.
My name's Manny Calavera.
Manny!
Oh.
I don't want a new travel agent.
I want to go home.
He's not the Grim Reaper.
You can't go home, Celso.
You're dead.
But you're not alone.
Everybody here is just as dead as you.
And I'm also dead, yeah.
The land of the dead.
Are you ready for your big journey?
I should be there.
What journey?
The four-year journey of the soul.
It is quite a big trip.
And I can't lie to you, Celso.
It could be very, very dangerous.
Unless you were to take that money you were buried with and
buy a better travel package, Gosh, this is so real.
Remember when I'm always talking about how I have to do
taxes and buy things and this and that.
Even though I'm dead, this is so real.
R slash Minto Hints.
It shoots straight to the 9th underworld.
The land of eternal rest in four minutes instead of four
years.
But very few people qualify.
Let's take a look at your records.
Squeaky clean.
what have I done couple of tricks up my sleeve here mm-hmm
yeah ha yes that's the ticket the Excelsior line oh she's a
beauty that compass in the handle no way oh you're going to
have a great trip wish I was going why don't you you you
could give me a lift oh i can't leave here until i've worked
off a little dead to the powers that be community service
huh well i guess there are some folks worse off than me oh
i'll be leaving here soon enough no thanks to dead and no
commission low-life cases like yours manso oh dang i thought
you were my friend hey manny the boss told me to tell you
not to leave early tonight he wants to talk to you about
something when he gets back from his trip tell don not to
worry i I do know, like, next to nothing about this game, so
I'm very excited.
Especially not with clients like that.
Oh, man.
Where do they get these guys?
They don't qualify for anything good, so I can't sell
anything good.
I can't work off my time, and I'm stuck.
Stuck selling walking sticks to a bunch of burros for
eternity.
Oh.
I need better clients.
I need a real saint.
I need a lead on a rich, dead saint.
Oh.
Hmm, what is this?
What is this?
Wait.
I'm going to scratch it.
Am I bawling?
This end cabin is where I hang my cloak.
Oh my gosh.
This end cabin is where I hang...
I should probably go investigate that thing.
But hold on, I'm discovering what the controls are.
Not picking that up.
I will probably just repeat things.
because i don't understand them oh it's looking good oh he's
still my computer gives me instant access to our database of
dead beats are these mori calliope fans wait a second
mean mean no toe uh-oh wait i want to see this again wait
what do you pick up here not portable Not portable.
Okay, let's investigate this thing.
What?
Oh, there's this thing, too.
Looks like I got a message.
Oh, that's what that is.
What's this?
Oh.
I don't know.
It's some sort of special work order.
To all agents from office manager Don Coppola.
All right, you boneheads.
Thank you, rookie stars, and get to your friggin' cars.
We have a mass poisoning on our hands.
Too many dead to assign specific cases.
So all clients are first come, first serve.
Let's see some hustle out there.
Sunships, thank you for that, Kasupa.
Whatever you say, Effie.
No, not the mass poisoning.
Wait, that's crazy.
What is this, too?
Oh, okay, we just...
My message tube is full of nothing.
As usual.
Alright, let's get out of here.
Doom-doom-doom-doom.
Is this how I leave?
No.
Oh, there's more over here.
What's this?
It's a deck of cards.
I'll take that.
Yoink.
Better take these cards.
It looks like a long...
day or solitaire for me the original controls for this game
are really bad so bad in fact there is an achievement for
playing the whole game with them they're in the options menu
if you want to take a shot no way it turns it into a rage
game that's hilarious what's this deck of cars just wouldn't
help there oh can i like put them in my inventory or i'm
just holding them for real
Where can I play my solitaire?
Blackjack!
Oh, the tank controls!
It did say that there were...
The deck of cards just wouldn't help there.
Alright, I'm just gonna take my cards and go.
Down.
This game does not automatically save.
Please save in the pause menu.
Okay.
The scary warning!
Scary!
Wait.
I'm gonna go talk to her.
Can I run?
Okay, there.
You have to double click a couple times.
That was such a big warning.
You will want a lot of saves.
Okay, I'll do a multiple.
Yeah, yeah.
Hello.
It's my boss's secretary, Ava.
It's my boss's whipping boy, Manny.
Why am I saying my inner thoughts out loud?
Buenos dias.
Manny, why aren't you at the poisoning?
Oh.
Any messages for me?
Besides the one about the poisoning?
Yeah.
I only have one other message for you, Manny.
Get to the poisoning.
I don't take your messages.
So get it through your thick skull and stop forwarding your
phone to me.
All right.
But that sounded more like four messages to me.
Busy as ever.
Busy as ever, I see.
I'd have more work to do if you had more clients.
Ouch.
They just want people to die.
I gotta go hit the bricks.
Okay.
You show those bricks a lesson Miss sassy pants big mr.
Boss man doesn't want to be disturbed today What's this now?
What is that?
My sight.
Oh, I like to keep it next to where my heart used to be
Okay, can I oh It's some sort of special work order This
deck of cards is a little freight around the edges then
again And so am I.
And I've got fewer suits.
All right, let's go.
It did look like nine chunks.
Domino's door is locked.
Probably scared I'll steal one of his files.
Not a bad idea, actually.
Oh, I'm glad he said files because I read it as flies.
I was like, who's stealing?
Was this what Skelly's eat?
I never knew.
Wait, what's in here?
Oh, double elevators?
Wait, what the hell?
Wait.
Huh?
What's over here?
Can I go in there?
I gotta find everything.
Went to the garage.
The garage.
Whoa!
This is how they store the...
Is that my car?
Here's what I need.
Wheels!
Ooh, I might get hurt if I try to get one down by myself.
No, it's easy.
It's so easy.
What's over here?
Hey, can you hear me one of these?
Hey, service.
Hey, who the...
Whoa.
What is that?
Sorry, sir.
I didn't expect the sales agents usually don't come over to
this part of the garage.
How are you?
I thought it was only skeletons.
How...
Nice hut.
Yeah, I wonder how nice it would seem to you if you were
trapped in it all day like me What is he?
He's a dog where
He has like a very like funny eel like face I'm man.
I'm man.
I'm calavera manny calavera call me manny.
It's what everyone calls me.
I don't get many visitors.
Hey, I got a message for a mr calavera uh your driver said
that mr hurley said that he could have the rest of the day
off domino said my driver off yeah wasn't that nice well are
you i need a driver looks like i need a new driver oh i uh i
uh i would agree with that yes you do you want to drive a
driver you a driver are you a driver no no no no i don't
ride them just wrench them you're a driver oh no wait
glottis glottis glottis is that a german name oh no my roots
lie not in any earthly nation soil i am an elemental spirit
summoned up from the land of the dead itself and given one
to drive cars to drive or to change oil and adjust timing
belts if no driving jobs are open yeah you want to be my you
want to be my replacement driver me oh oh no sorry can't no
rules rules come on glottis what rule who said who made the
rules who even made the rules me
He's so, oh no, he's like, he's really moly.
Come on, Gladys.
I need you to be my driver.
Gladys!
No, I can't.
I'm, I'm, I'm too big.
What?
Oh.
You're not too big.
You're just right.
You just have a self-image problem.
Okay, see you later, chicken.
Wait, we could probably instigate, like kind of, he might be
like, I'm not a chicken.
You know?
No, I want to see you.
You just have self-image problems.
You're not too big.
You just have a self-image problem.
A what?
Repeat after me.
I am not fat.
I am thin.
Women find me attractive.
Hey, I never said I was too fat for the ladies, just the
cars.
The ladies like me just fine.
You know who he reminds me of?
He kind of reminds me of Frog Bird.
Something about, I think him and Frogbert would be...
Would it be good friends?
Oh, screw the rules!
Screw the rules!
Come with me.
No!
I don't want to get in trouble again!
They said one more strike and I'm out!
There's something really about him.
Okay, see you later.
I'm gonna okay, I'm gonna risk it.
I'm gonna risk it.
I'm gonna call him a chicken.
Okay.
See you later chicken.
Yeah, okay Oh, no, no, no, no, no, come back.
Oh, no, no, no.
Oh, no, no.
I hate to watch you go, but I love to see you walk away.
Hey, genie.
Come out of the lantern already.
Here he comes again.
He's a speed demon get it?
Boy, don't.
I need you to be my driver.
Come on, Gladys.
I need you to be be my driver I told you I'm too big I'm too
big you're just right big you're just right no they told me
again and again I'm too big to drive the cars are too small
not too big the cars are just too small yeah those dang
compact cars hey I could Gladys confirmed to not be Marty
McClatch.
To let out the seams, you know?
But I'm not allowed to modify the cars without a work order
from upstairs.
I could lose my job.
A work order, huh?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I can't torch anything bigger than a cigarette without one
of these signed by the boss himself.
Hey, that's my line, getting people to sign.
Back in a snap.
Yeah, too small.
I'm not too big.
Everything around here is just too small.
So true, buddy.
Well, we came in here.
We didn't even...
Wait, what is this?
We didn't even try to go through the other elevator.
Run.
That won't help it get signed.
What the hell, Maddie?
so slowly all the way here.
That won't help it get signed.
What is this thing?
No, no, please!
Oh, my God.
Okay, you gotta run over to the thing?
What is this?
That won't help it get signed.
Is there a way to put my items in my inventory?
Sure, sure, sure.
I hear you.
I hear you, buddy.
We need to get a sign.
You need to put away the work order.
Yeah, but I don't know how.
Right click?
I've got to get this work order signed.
Oh, there.
Oh, it's literally...
Oh, sorry.
It was this little button behind me.
That.
Okay, okay.
I learned.
Let's go investigate what this is now.
Oh, shoot.
Okay.
Check it out.
It's a thing.
It's going to say...
There are lights for wash, rinse, wax, and land of the
living, depending on your destination.
That's all-in-one.
Wow.
The driver demons operate this somehow, and the company
won't tell a salesman how it works.
Gotta keep us down somehow.
So you're just trapped in the building until you need to go?
Okay.
Alrighty.
Switch the tank control.
I'll try.
Wait, where is it?
Is it tank controls?
Here we go.
What is...
What are tank controls?
Wait, how am I playing any different?
It's a hole punch.
I'm taking it?
Could I take your hole punch?
I doubt you can take my half punch.
Dang.
Aero keys.
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
But I'm still clicking and pointing.
It's my boss's secretary, Ava.
It's my boss's whipping boy, Manny.
Oh, it really is like a tank.
Okay.
We're walking.
We're fine.
Big Mr. Boss man doesn't want to be disturbed today.
Wait, no, I have something though.
I need him to sign my work.
I really need the boss to sign this work order.
I'll give it a shot.
Thank you.
Mr. Coppola, I've got Manny Calavera out here to see you.
Didn't I say no interruptions today?
Eh, sorry, Cal.
Maybe tomorrow.
That's too late.
Oh, yeah, like you're going anywhere.
Was I not supposed to go to the poison?
Keyboard only.
Oh.
I slowly back away.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
It's not so bad when you remember how tank controls work.
I slowly moonwalk away.
Oh gosh.
I slowly...
What is that thing?
Oh, oops.
Yes.
Okay.
All right.
It's locked.
You're locked.
What the heck is this thing?
I can take it?
Ah, the old head of the department.
Way before my time.
I heard he was a total slave driver.
What happened to him?
Yeah, right.
Uh-uh-uh-uh-uh-uh-uh.
Someone's cigarette.
Who else is here?
Let's see.
Where am I on this?
Don Copal, Domino Hurley, Junior Sales Associates.
That better not be me.
No, I've been here much longer.
All right.
It's locked.
Okay.
I gave up on tank controls.
Honestly, I'm fine with just pointing and clicking anyway.
Wait, so...
I didn't even realize you could walk with the keyboard
anyway.
Kind of.
Man, he struggles downstairs.
There he goes.
He's so fast.
Is this my car?
Wait, this says no parking.
No parking.
Client car pickup only.
Who's this?
It's mine.
Mr. Minto.
Thank you, Crafty.
Oh, I sold so many car travel packages when I was first
starting out.
When did I lose my age?
Can I take it?
I left my tow truck back in my other suit.
We can't operate cars.
That's how they keep us from skipping town.
Oh, so that's why we need the drive.
Never.
Just start running, babe.
I'm not walking on the freeway.
Why not?
I shouldn't even be standing here.
What are you gonna do?
Die?
Don't be ridiculous, Manny.
Come on.
Whoa!
Wait, is this the poison?
It's a celebration!
Everybody's dead!
Meantau, getting the old school tank control experience from
Group Radego is making me wonder how she'll fare.
the non the og non remakes of resident evil i have played
those games it's hellish for me
hey buddy is this gonna help me get my thing signed looks
like some sort of crafty mine a crafty mine what's going
down clown get back off suit i'm practicing
i have to go that sound makes me what i kill somebody it's
so true though practicing what ring in your neck what does
it look like twist me up one come on yeah I want one of them
twist me up one of them huh fella yeah yeah yeah twist this
all right what's that supposed to mean but you can't do a
cat bet you can't do a cat shows what you know buddy I can
do anything anything I can do birds and famous poets go
ahead name one Robert Frost wait oh my gosh I actually like
Robert Frost's work Robert Frost trying to stump me eh oh oh
my god that's so impressive oh it's mine I'll keep that what
else got what else he got Um, my kid wants another balloon
animal.
My kid wants another balloon animal.
Ah, jeez.
What now?
I bet you can't do Robert Frost again.
Did you lose the one I gave you?
No.
Well, then just enjoy it for a while longer, all right?
What about a dead worm?
A dead worm.
Heck, that's easy.
Oh, yes.
There's no limit.
on those oh I could keep getting dead worms awesome I'm
gonna stick that in my pocket wait I need another thing can
I get through your tent I want to see the parade well walk
through someone else's tent all right do I look like a turn
style to you could you teach me how to do that well since
you're a beginner why don't you practice the first step
which is blow Bang!
Popped another one.
Lousy bony fingers.
Did I do that with my mind?
She's telling me to blow.
I kind of like his sass.
I do too.
Hmm.
Some festival, eh?
Yeah.
Yeah, pretty busy.
My carpal tunnel syndrome's really acting up.
But you don't have any That's all I was about to say.
But that doesn't seem to shut you up now, does it?
This guy's full of all sorts of retorts, huh?
Okay, man.
I want another one.
Once another balloon in a little time.
Jeez, what now?
Uh, a dingo.
A dingo?
That's my specialty.
No way.
Oh.
How the hell did he do that?
He even changed the color.
Oh, get a balloon twister to pop a balloon.
Lousy bony.
Oh, I just got the achievement.
That's so funny.
Some of my finest work.
Don't you think, Sparky?
Okay, well, maybe I can...
I gotta get him to approve my...
What's in the back alley?
I gotta get him to approve my work order somehow, but he
doesn't want to be interrupted.
What is this?
Let me put this away real quick.
I don't like the way that eye is looking at me.
Not picking that up.
Hmm.
Is there only just the one?
What else is down here?
What's that?
Oh, climb?
We're going up, baby.
Um.
Oh my god, even the birds are skeletons.
What the heck is that noise?
I'm bus- Ah.
Whose room is this?
What a thrill.
What is this?
That's me like in this game.
I feel like I'm six years old.
It looks like Don's rigged his computer to automatically
answer his intercom.
Not picking that up.
Oh.
Not now, Eva.
I'll have to wait.
I'm in a fiddle of a very important meeting.
Didn't I say...
Whatever it is, it will have to wait.
Ah, cripes, Eva.
Just sign it yourself, will ya?
I'm busy.
Eva, please...
Oh, okay, so probably this one.
Tell them the checks aren't here yet.
I'm on the phone.
If you buzz me again, I swear I'll jump out this window.
Okay, we'll get her to sign it.
Oh, where is it?
Oh.
Wait, where'd he go?
I'll just change his auto-response.
Yeah, there we go.
I'm right, babe.
I just sign it yourself, will you?
I'm busy.
Let's go!
Hello?
Oh, sorry.
Hello, my wife.
This place is a mess.
How do we get into his office?
I would love to search Don's office right now, but I'm late
for the poisoning.
Okay, I'm late for the poisoning.
I do want to search.
though wait did he escape through memo from the desk of don
copal hey work orders are assigned by my office and are not
exchangeable among salesmen swapping selling and specially
stealing work orders will result in severe disciplinary
action swapping selling stealing this place is a mess when i
hear him all i hear is hey i'm working here Thinking about
Don's file system gives me a cold chill.
I would love to search Don's office.
No time to ransack.
Everybody's at the poisoning.
That's right.
I gotta get a high hitter.
I gotta get someone awesome that will make me rise up in the
ranks.
Oh, look at this little guy.
Too cute.
Makes me so happy you're finally playing this.
Me too.
Oh.
Here I go.
Wait, I just took it.
Go down.
That's what I'm saying, dummy.
Oh, what if I threw it over there?
Wait a second.
Hold on.
What if I want to keep going up?
Wait.
I'm not done there.
Go up.
Go back up, Maddie.
What a thrill.
It's not quite thrilling.
Well, it is thrilling music, but not quite the music.
we would, you know.
Hold on.
Strong as hell.
This guy is literally a sack of bones.
He weighs nothing.
Oh, come on.
Manny.
Try harder.
Maybe the other side.
Come on.
Put your...
What's a bone in your arm?
I don't have bones.
Put your humorous.
Where is...
The funny...
Put your funny bone into it.
Not picking that up.
No, just go.
Let me leave.
Juta Stray, thank you so much for that, the boy.
you LucasArts game trying to get Indiana Minto for real put
your weenus I haven't heard that in a long time wait what do
I have here that could be used for this eyeball you deck of
cars just wouldn't help there and why not and why not what
What if he will sign it?
That won't help it get signed.
This guy, come on, you haven't even tried.
What is that?
Eww!
What if he's a fan of Robert Frost?
So close.
Alright, well we got our work order signed, so...
Oh wait, it's over here.
And in here.
There we go.
Robert Frost balloon.
No, no, no, no, no, no, put it away.
Pizza party stream was on my birthday and tragically missed
it.
No!
Time-traveling fetus.
Can I get a late happy birthday, please?
Happy birthday!
Luckily, I was able to sing happy birthday to you on that
day.
Hi, B-B.
Hello!
Thanks for the super tag.
Let's get this work order.
It's a deflate.
No, it's a dead worm.
It even...
Do you hear the sound?
All right, Eva.
Eva, I really need the boss to sign this work order.
I'll give it a shot.
Okay, this should work.
This should work.
Mr. Coppola, Mr. Calavera has something out here that he
says he needs your signature on.
Ah, Christ, Eva, just sign it yourself, will you?
I'm busy.
Yeah.
You'll have to excuse him, Manny.
It's probably a really hard crosswood puzzle he's got in
there today.
Even she knows he's not doing jack- I had no idea you had
this kind of power.
Well, we all have our secrets.
Oh, whoa.
Oh my god, this cinematic transition.
That was crazy.
Making a convertible!
Gladys!
Hey, I look good in this, don't I?
Every time he starts talking.
I'm driving, yeah!
I'm driving!
Oh my god.
I think we've missed it already is he not a speed oh what is
happening what the hell is this
oh domino they got a good one huh ew what the the creeps
it's the poisoning
look at these poor saps can you talk to them it's the fear
of death that makes monsters of us all wait what did he say
scaring the living is technically against the rules but we
We all do it.
Oh, scare the living a few times.
Smiles as bright and wide as the blade on my scythe.
If I scare them to death, then they'll become a customer.
But I'll get nailed with a conflict of interest wrap.
What about this?
I'll take that.
I can't reap hamburger, cows, or a whole other bureau, not
to mention the lettuce.
Oh, you can reap.
In this world, all I can do is look, smell, and reap.
That's torture.
Look at that borg.
Look at the size of that thing.
That's a big smile for a waitress at a mass poisoning.
Well, you know.
Truth be told, I'd rather be setting this milkshake soul
free.
I think we know our culprit then, huh?
I mean, the police is just taking a load off and everything.
Do I need my scythe out?
Oh, dude.
Time to reap.
Come here, little guy.
Oh, get the right angle.
Oh, he is a little guy, isn't he?
Hello, little guy.
His first and last words.
Can you imagine if his last words were...
Cut the yeah.
If I want something cheap where I can get some rest, that's
it.
His last words were nice bathroom.
His first words.
Yeah, yeah, whatever.
Oh yeah, slam the front into the weeds, tub the rear end, do
blowers, pop it out of the hood.
You'll get plenty of rest as well, Mr. Martinez can be
safely patted by the phone created when there's two
chemicals mixed like this.
On second thought, I wanna upgrade my package.
Sorry, Bruno, but you didn't qualify for anything better.
She's getting- have this complimentary mug it's the first
day of the end of your life can't you find me something
where i can move my legs nope you know i'd like to bruno but
my boss is a real hard ass i gotta be a hard ass when i got
lazy sickle waivers like this jolly boy working for me hey
where were you you couldn't find a sale at a yacht club i
got a sale right here i'm talking premium sales calabera
Like the kind Domino makes.
How am I supposed to make premium sales with the scumbag
clients you're sending me?
Hey, now you're blaming the clients?
I've had it with you, Manny.
If you haven't bagged a premium before the next sales report
comes in, you're out.
Where do I go?
No job.
No way to work off your time.
Just your fancy suit and your big smile and a whole lot of
time to kill.
What are you calling a scumbag client?
Fill his mouth with sand.
yeah get faked mister I'm sick of waiting around for a good
lead like it's gonna fly in here tied to a brick it's time
to take one oh I was gonna say it could
man I'm so sad hey you missed a great poisoning hey you
missed a great poisoning yeah and you missed a great client
domino came back from there with a I got a tiny little man
with a mean temper and no commission well at least you don't
work for one in my heart though you're still my secretary
why would I say that in my heart though you're still my
secretary Manny what are you talking about I was never your
secretary even when you were on top we were on top same as
you Don Coppola we were on top I know you work for another
man man besides dawn what what are you talking about I know
you take memos for Hurley sometimes oh man he just beat it
will ya Hurley well you going to the Christmas party so you
going to the Christmas party after the spectacle you made of
yourself last year I wouldn't miss it for the world what are
you talking about any good gossip any good gossip well I
heard domino got a raise that's not gossip tell me some good
news why don't you I still love you.
You're all I really need, Beyesa.
Ooh, la la.
I can't find my driver.
Manny, do I have to explain your job to you again?
Uh... but I... no, but I'd like to hear...
No, but I'd like to hear your description of it.
Just for kicks.
Well, the Manuel Calavera than I know picks up people in the
land of the living.
Mm-hmm.
Dead people?
Preferably.
And he brings them here and tries valiantly to sell them the
best travel package they qualify for.
Yes.
will be free to leave the land of the dead.
Until then, he and I are stuck here having the same
conversation over and over again for eternity.
What's so bad about here, though?
I mean...
I guess if your boss is a doo-doo head, it's kind of
annoying, but like...
What if he just wanted to, like, chill as a Skellyman?
I guess it's just boring.
Monotonous?
I guess so.
Hmm.
As you play the game, you'll find out this place sucks.
Oh.
What if we just skip town tonight?
You and me, baby.
Well, thanks for the offer, but we never make it out of the
city alive.
We're dead!
We're in one piece.
I mean.
I bet I could get you out if I really tried.
Oh, Manny, look at you.
You're a trapezoan.
You don't even know it.
I think I know it.
What did you do in life to get stuck here?
Why does some client...
We know this one.
It's because of their...
holiness they're so they're sin free they lived they lived
they didn't even step on an aunt in their lives all right
how did you do in life to get stuck here what i did back in
the fat days is none of your business you know the rules
okay well i gotta go get karma they had good karma oh talk
to eva about how she got stuck here oh What is that horrible
squeaking noise you're making?
New shoes.
Why do I sound like that?
Oh, his door is open now.
Oh.
Hello, friend.
Are you my friend?
Who are you?
Those pictures come with the frames.
Wait, I thought I was talking to him.
That suit come with those holes.
Well, at least you're not hitting the bottle anymore.
Hey, Kelly.
How you doing?
We just go into people's offices to instigate.
Trouble?
How'd you make out of the poisoning?
So, how'd you make out of the poisoning?
Well, let's just say that Sister Calabaza has a secret
passion.
What's that?
For trains.
You got a nun?
Hail Mary.
And you sold her a ticket on the number nine train.
Wow.
Chew, true little buddy.
Oh, so is this Domino?
Say, how'd you score?
I got...
Two nuns.
I got two nuns actually.
Hey, that reminds me of this really funny joke.
Heard it.
I want to punch you in the mouth.
Or kiss you on the mouth.
What if it's like those telltale games where it's just like
you say, it says one thing, you know?
It'll say like, I want to punch you in the mouth.
And he says, and then, but it actually changes the meaning
of what you write earlier.
Like, you know, like, it's not what you write.
Like, you know what I mean?
Where it says, like, I want to punch you in the mouth, or
maybe kiss you on the mouth.
You select that answer not knowing, and they're going to say
the second part, and it just totally changes the direction
of your choice.
You know?
I want to tell you something.
Go on and let it all out, Manny.
There's no reason for you to be afraid of me.
I think we should be partners.
I think we should team up.
Be partners.
would but i'm too intimidated i could never be partners with
someone who was so much more of a man than me oh come on
i've seen your wife i think you're up to something i think
you're up to something yeah i'm up to about four premium
sales this week your brain is a fantastic mental okay that's
the end of that lecture well thank you for those words of
wisdom No, not the Christmas party all over again.
What happened to the Christmas party?
What happened at the Christmas party?
Uh-oh, we don't remember.
Black out on the whole thing, huh?
Maybe you should switch to lemonade, kid.
I got something else to tell you.
I've got something else to tell you.
Let's have it.
No, I don't.
Never mind.
On second thought, I don't.
Well, thank you for those words of wisdom.
I want to ask you a question.
Shoot, slugger.
Kiss.
Is it hard to kiss up to the boss so much when you got no
lips?
Hey, I got all the lip I need.
I get it from you.
What did you do to get this job?
You mean what's my secret to success?
No, I mean how did you screw up and get stuck here at the
DoD?
What sin did you commit and how long are you going to have
to work here to pay it off?
Well, I could easily ask the same question of you.
But I don't know the answer.
I still don't know what I've done.
Wait, so he actually doesn't know his, like, past life or
whatever.
Can I have one of your clients?
Yeah, yeah.
Sure, Cal.
Just as soon as I get what I think you could handle.
I can handle anything you got, especially if that's your
best right job.
Dang.
I don't want to know.
Why do you get all the good clients?
Yeah, why do you?
You're asking the wrong guy.
You should be taking a good long look at the man in the
mirror.
No, thanks.
Man in the mirror.
Okay, bye.
Well, see you in limbo.
Oh, that's great.
We should do this more often.
I think he hates me.
What you got going on over here?
I'm snooping.
What the heck is this?
Hey, Dom.
What's your screensaver password?
Get away from my computer, Manny.
Not portable.
Dang it.
We're leaving.
Oh, we're leaving.
Oh, hi.
Hi!
Hi Manny!
You have something?
Can you see me?
Manny?
My boss is always giving me these motivational sales books.
They bought the farm and I'll sell them the cows.
Stuff like that.
So, is there anything else that we have to do over here?
Oh, there is the parade, doll.
I should close Bruno's record before the black marks burn
into my screen.
All right, we did that.
I guess we did that.
Not portable.
My computer gives me instant access to our database of dead
beats.
What's in here?
This end cabin is where I hang my cloak.
Oh, it's cloak.
It's cloak.
Um...
Yeah, let's save again, right?
Yeah.
I don't know how often I need to save, but I'll save.
Just remind me sometimes.
Let's see.
What do we got in here?
That thing.
What if we use the cards?
Because the clown...
Hi, Manny.
Bye, Manny.
We could try using the cards on the clown.
See if it'd be like, do you know any card tricks or
something?
Save after every puzzle.
I'm confused.
Or rather, not confused.
But I'm just wondering why.
people say to save so much you and your fancy suits and your
nose holes way up in the air sticking your empty beer
bottles down the message tubes how fancy is that huh don't
you boys upstairs realize the tube switcher is a
sophisticated and delicate piece of machinery oh it's not
garbage you think you're better than me no good
the game old game used to crash that's all okay okay i
wasn't sure if it was like a you'll get soft locked kind of
situation or yeah huh what the heck is going on in here that
red tube looks familiar is that to dawn domino mr mr guy you
won't turn and the door won't budge wait but there's this
thing right over here
Grab that.
It's so loud.
I would
touch anything more sophisticated and delicate than myself.
You can absolutely get softlocked in this game due to bugs.
Ah!
Unless it...
Not picking that up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right, hold on.
There was another door, right?
We want to get to the red tube to do something.
send him Robert Frost balloon animal what the heck is this
one of the chemicals for our packing material comes ah yes
for those who enjoy no hassle travel oh wait what if I fill
up the dead worm with the stuff.
Now I have that.
What comes out of this thing?
Oh.
That smell.
It's a lump of our packing foam.
Does this also make a lump?
Oh, goodbye.
Did he, how many worms did he give me?
Maybe I need more than one.
Okay, let's go get another worm.
Because he said that there were unlimited worms, no?
I mean, I thought he meant that, you know, not seriously,
but I think he actually means it seriously.
He did say that, yeah, he said there's no limit, right?
He said, so...
I would like to go to the parade give me give me give me a
dead worm I'm not sure what I'm doing with these yet, but
Geez what now More worms more dead worms back there well
sure Green
It's probably fine, right?
I'm not sure what I need to do with it, but I feel like I
need to do it you know yeah put the worm in the mail tube
that's what i'm thinking i'm not sure why i would do that is
what i'm you know what i mean okay wait a second that was
purple oh oh it was green when he gave it to me i saw it
let's just slip that in there but how do I get it to open
the
door won't budge unless what if we go up to the office what
was the office with the red tube was it was it Domino's hmm
maybe you want to make him look bad right is my guess
Excuse me.
He's got a lock on it.
I can't believe he doesn't trust me.
I mean, with what we're trying to do.
What's this?
Oh, damn!
Oh!
Okay, what is this?
That's some premium looking scotch.
Scotch?
Just so you don't forget what premium tastes like.
He has a lock on it.
How do I unlock it?
not picking that up no messages in dom's fancy red too
there is one in ours yes but he's got a lock on it i can't
believe he doesn't trust me i don't know where he would have
a uh look at all the diplomas you have to have the proper
attitude to get diplomas like those manny really i thought
you just had to have the proper For some reason, I have the
impression that you run the same way as Bayani.
What does that mean?
Who's this skeleton halogen?
Wait, there it is.
Peep in the drawer.
Desk drawers?
I don't have desk drawers.
Hey, get out of there, Calavera.
Stop, stop.
We need to get this guy out of here.
Can you leave?
Scalagon.
I've got something else to tell you.
Let's have it.
You know, this used to be my office.
Yeah, I know.
I found your name on some comic books in the desk.
I want my office back.
Don't worry.
You'll have years and years to enjoy it after I get promoted
out and you're still here.
No.
Well, you sound pretty out of breath.
So I'm gonna blow always a pleasure, Cal.
Okay.
Why aren't you doing work now, huh?
What if I do it in mine, though?
Oh, hi, Maddie.
Why does he look at me?
Oh, no, it's open.
Open it up.
Yeah, how is he...
That's just disgusting.
How is he sweating?
Was it this one?
Uh-oh, wait, I can't...
They're both the same.
Uh...
This balloon is filled with a dark chemical.
A dark chemical.
This balloon is filled with a light chemical.
This balloon is filled with a dark chemical.
Huh?
Just send them both?
Okay.
Ew!
Look out below.
Okay.
we'll do the other one.
Maybe then it'll make the foe, or no.
Oh yeah, because they wouldn't, I put it on the table, and
then it mixed with the other thing it made the foam.
That doesn't sound good.
Oops.
Well.
Get foamed.
the server's down again what else is new was it this one
yeah the other one goes to the garage
now what's going on in here
hello hi i'm not getting any messages is the server down oh
this is their idea of a joke they think it's funny i'd like
to jam their tubes with back material see how they're like
that oh who would do a terrible thing who would do a
terrible thing like this who's those punks in the mail room
they think this baby is going to put them out of a job right
oh dang machines taking our jobs right guys am I right I
thought the phone was pretty funny I'm I'm I'm chuckling I'm
raffling right now.
I'm raffling.
So you're saying the server is down.
Is that it?
The server is not down.
It's never down.
It's just temporarily unavailable while I'm doing some
maintenance.
That's all.
So how long is it going to be down?
With a job like this, you can never tell.
Probably ours.
Or until no one's around to see you sneak out, eh?
Whichever comes first.
The solution here is so easy to overlook.
Let's see if I can find it.
puzzle that makes the wait this is the part that makes the
puzzle hard you need to do something specific and it's easy
to miss okay okay okay okay okay okay it doesn't have to do
with talking doctor special about you i sir am an elemental
spirit summoned from the land of the dead itself oh it's
your purpose yes your purpose is to fix the tube one desire
yeah fixing pneumatic tubes thank you so much i was created
to run the elevators but they put in those dang motion
detectors and put me out of work oh
you know i really think it's clean enough oh it's clean
enough to run all right i'm just fiddling around to be safe
you know Gotta cover my ass.
Yes, you do.
Dang, he cleaned up the foam so fast.
Just curious.
How'd you get in there?
I squeezed out one of these tubes like a pixie.
What do you think I got in here?
Through the door.
I squeezed out one of these tubes.
Like a pixie.
Hey, me too.
I'll let you go.
This guy has a cool name.
Not that I'm biased or anything.
Maddie, thank you.
All right, let's see.
Not again.
Ah, ah, ah, ah.
You trying to blow this joint sky high?
That's a magnesium compound fire extinguisher.
Yeah?
Spray that on this packing foam, and we'll both be riding
the giant Roman candle out of here.
Wait, that's kind of great.
Why would they put something so dangerous in here?
I guess they didn't expect this room to be full of hazardous
waste.
Okay.
Talk to Brennis about how we got to the machine.
Okay, um, let's see.
I cut open his pants.
But also, what if?
That's not on fire.
Oh, it could be.
I thought about, I don't think I can lock him in, right?
The wheel won't budge.
It's the wheel on the door.
The wheel on the door does not budge, does not budge, does
not budge.
The wheel on the door does not budge.
Wait a second, what's going on here?
Wait, I don't even know what I clicked.
Can't reach.
Oh.
What if I reach with my size?
No.
What?
I can extend it and reach it.
No, I'll...
What I'm thinking is I'm trying to...
forward his mail to my mailbox so I end up getting the the
good the good clients hold on let's go look over here no
bugs bunny meme no
you had the right idea okay I'm cooking cool
Take a car Just wouldn't help there
Can't reach
Robert Frost Deploying the frost
Wait Oh no it didn't do anything actually Okay Come on,
don't you want to see my really cool balloon?
Manny?
Are you okay, buddy?
Is
there another direction I can go in?
He's Blair witching you guys!
Oh my god, Manny!
No!
Maddie!
Don't go into the woods!
Do you want a hint?
Let me look at my inventory one more time.
Let me look at my inventory one more time and see if I get a
brain blast.
That's not on fire.
It could be!
I don't know!
Dang!
Look at that crap!
Bullseye.
Manny, are you okay?
Are you okay?
Are you okay, Manny?
What if I...
Not here.
Not here?
What do you mean?
As if there's a time and a place to take out...
What?
Do I need a time and a place to whip out my size?
You need...
When you drink five hour energy drinks.
Oh, five, five hour.
Let's go see if there's something else in the...
Oh!
Good enough for government work.
Wait, do I have to redo this now?
Oh, man.
Ah, no!
No!
Oops.
That's okay.
Just go get some more deadlifts.
worms.
Oh, I could reload.
You're so right.
There was this one, right?
I set them down.
Pretty sure.
Yeah.
Okay.
Just so I don't have to go fill them up and then send it
again and do the whole thing again.
All right.
There's no limit on those.
Yeah, my worms.
Server's down again.
What else is new?
Well, before we go in there, I guess, let me see if there's
anything.
Nothing new in here.
What's that thing?
There she is.
The number nine.
One of these days, I'm gonna ride her right on out of here.
Nice.
All right.
I
can help you.
You're trying to blow this, that's why.
Sorry, we already heard this, so.
Ah,
cheerful communications maintenance staff is on the job.
Oh, oops.
This is the answer.
It's with the power we can add in.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
All right, deploying Robert Frost once again.
Dang it.
I need a hint!
Switcher looks pretty gunked up.
As a rule, I never touch anything more sophisticated and
delicate than myself I think I'd need a hint you're on the
right track with the door oh was I how to keep the door from
locking not right no come on Manny it'll work oh there you
go cars just wouldn't help there yes you could it in the
lock it won't wait a deck of cars just wouldn't help there
oh no stinking way
i've just locked an open door strange yet symbolically
compelling
this is the reason gamer paint exists the dead boat looks
set oh my god
If only it were bright yellow.
La,
la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la.
We'll save over this one.
You guys are...
Uh, let's just, uh, break it.
What do you say?
What if I break it with the...
With this guy?
That's not on fire.
Oh, come on.
It's locked.
Not picking that up.
I think that's the other end of Domino's message, too.
If I could just get in there.
Robert Frost!
I choose you!
Can I, like, turn the wheel?
To open it?
This?
Oh.
This right here?
It's locked.
Uh, what did he do?
Oh wait, maybe I actually can use the cards here because he
pulled out that...
Yeah, yeah, he pulled that thing, yeah.
The little gunky out of it.
Hmm, too much air pressure.
Um, what else do I have?
A dingo.
On the right track, yeah.
Not right now.
No, not even the tip of the side.
Do I need something else?
I don't think I have anything else.
Yeah, I don't have anything else, so...
I think I have to come back for it, no?
I
never touch anything more sophisticated and delicate than
myself.
Not picking that up.
Modify the card.
But like, how?
Like, you can't...
It doesn't allow you to modify items.
This deck of cards is a little freight around the edges.
Then again, so am I.
And I've got fewer suits.
How are you supposed to modify it?
Or do I fill it with bone?
It doesn't let you combine items, so...
Deck of cards just wouldn't help there.
How do I modify it?
Ugh, I...
Deck of cards just wouldn't help there.
Oh, uh, what about our hole punch?
Can I leave, please?
If it's there's too much air pressure, we can just have the
air, the whole, the, the, what's it called?
Um, the air goes through it a little bit, right?
I don't know.
I don't know if that logic is sound or not.
Oh my god!
Wait, my work.
Manny, what are you doing?
Just marking cards, honey.
Wait, is this gonna work?
Do I look like I studied physics?
I have no idea.
Alright.
Ah, yeah.
Number 9308, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Diet of chickenpox, time of death, yada, yada, yada.
of attributes volunteer time reading stories to die that's
good that's really good I think you're in Mercedes Colomar I
think you're the one for me okay we let's go find a guy mr.
Colomar glades are you local what got into you it was a
company car oh yeah and it's even better company oh my god
he's so he's gone crazed
Oh, we can totally beat anybody trying to go there, though.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, wait.
This is a kind of car a reaper should be driving.
Buenos dias.
You're not the nurse?
No.
You're not here to give me my medication?
No, but I am here to ease your pain.
Guess they couldn't save me, huh?
Oh, no.
But there's still a chance you could save me.
That's a lot of responsibility, Mr. Calavera.
What makes you think I've been all that good?
Miss Colomar.
Meche, please.
Meche.
I can see it in your face and in your file here, where it
says you're entitled to a first-class ticket to...
To Goodsville.
Oh.
What?
Did I do something wrong?
Not according to your bio.
It was spotless.
At least the part I read was...
I'm not sure I like the implication, Mr. Calavera.
Are you sure you're Mercedes Colomar?
Would you like to see my birthmark?
Where is it?
It's wherever you guys put my skin.
Anything you haven't told me?
Anything about your past you haven't told me?
Quite a bit.
Considering I've told you nothing.
Did you kill much?
Yeah, how many ants did you kill?
Did you kill much when you were alive?
Very little.
Never killed anybody.
I have to confess, I never killed anybody.
That sounded like, you know, when people chop up people's...
Like, before deepfakes, when audio was chopped up to, like,
make the person sound like they were saying something, I
never killed anybody.
Not a teensy bit of killing.
Not even a teensy bit of killing.
Maybe I just wasn't trying hard enough.
Ever cheated on your taxes?
That's the second worst thing, killing somebody.
Yeah, the splicing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Ever cheated on your taxes?
I've never paid taxes in my life.
Oh.
I've never made enough money to be taxed.
You know, it's mostly been all volunteer work.
Mm-hmm.
were you mean to animals oh no i love animals once when i
was volunteering at an animal shelter i just stop right
there you've cheated on your husband your husband mr
calavera there's no ring on my finger there's no skin either
there's no skin on it either i guess you'll just have to
oh gosh oh no i'm getting too in tuned with the game you
guys were you a shoplifter a big shoplifter well they
accused me of it once really but it wasn't my fault that
puppy followed me out of the store right the next game now
you were a litterer oh manny is that the best you can do
she's like think of something else really crazy think of a
recent a bunch of people the big poisoning event work with
me machi give me some dirt well i could do something bad
right now if that would help wouldn't count sorry i give up
don't say that manny excuse me but i have to go straight in
this mess out sorry to be so much trouble mr calavera it's
no trouble but please call me manny what could she have done
so it's fine to sync with him so true why is it why is it
not working is it because i just don't understand it why
can't i find anything good for mechi is it because actually
what if she well no she's not married to she said no ring on
her finger i was gonna say what if she's married to like a
mafia man but what if it's that our computer is like
programmed to where we can never give a good thing you know
what i mean We've been, we've been sabotaged.
I'm sorry I let you down, Manny.
What do you mean?
Why'd you say that?
Hey, funny bones!
In my office!
Now!
You vandalized company property in order to obtain secret
information so you could take your illegally modified
company car and your unregistered driver and run domino
here.
All in order to steal a client from her legitimate agent.
There's nothing legitimate about this place.
You give all the good clients the domino.
Manny, now I'm embarrassed for you.
You've embarrassed the whole office.
I'm going to call the woman in here so you can apologize to
her yourself.
Ava, send in Ms. Colomar, please.
She left about 15 minutes ago.
What?
Why'd she leave?
She said she had a long walk ahead of her and she wanted to
get started.
Why does she think she has to walk?
That's the best package I could find for her.
Now you see why I give all the good clients to Domino.
Domino, you hacked my computer!
I'm going to shoe in for a double-end ticket that she's not
going to get because you just couldn't find it.
And now, because of your little stunt, she's out there.
On her own, walking by herself through the petrified forest,
facing the demons of the underworld alone and unprotected.
after a lifetime of hardship and public service her destiny
stolen by some overreaching salesman looking for a fat
commission he didn't deserve get in there and stay put until
the boys downtown tell us what they want done we're in the
boys room someone's gonna take the fall for this Calavera
and it ain't gonna be me he put us in the men's room no but
also my driver took the day off what was I don't see anyone
out there.
Is that a sexy calendar?
It looks like it dispenses something called philodent.
Philodent.
Can I just leave?
Oh.
Hello?
Hey!
Is anybody out there?
So, Manuel.
Have you thought about what you have done?
Oh, who's that?
I'm thinking about getting out and getting even.
thinking about getting out and getting even yeah the only
way out Manuel is to be taking back in if you are truly
still loyal to this company declare it loudly the management
might hear and stick you right back in their fold the DOD
runs a crooked game yeah yeah the DOD runs a crooked game
and I intend to prove it yeah who is this guy all I want is
my job back all I want is my job back I see well keep up the
faith I
wish the music didn't stop like you know hello hey guard
how's my little count of Monte Cristo who's out there ready
for walkies or rather I was you years ago yeah well I'm me
now so get lost few years ago wait what I gotta open that
door for me amigo look you gotta open the door for me amigo
if you are still loyal lay down and roll over and bark the
company fight song I know my loyalty my loyalty still to the
DoD believe it are not good boy you just keep up that spirit
and i'm sure you'll get out of here soon enough let me out
let me out my walkies how's my little count of monte cristo
no really who are you no really who are you i'm a fellow
prisoner my friend maybe but your cell's a lot bigger than
mine jail mate What are they gonna do to me?
What are they gonna do to me?
I don't want to alarm you, Agent Calavera.
But have you ever seen a man sprouted?
Sprouted?
What does that mean?
Welcome back to Vim Push-Up!
Thank you!
I don't go to those parties anymore.
I think it was during...
Wait, what do you mean?
Yeah, what do you mean, sprouted?
What do you mean, sprouted?
Then you don't know.
There's nothing more horrible than the bite of the sprouter.
Its deadly stinger spreads a green disease through every
calcified pore on your body.
Leaving you veined with roots and flocked with grass
steadily growing thicker and thicker until you crash and
bloom out in a horrifying bouquet of pain and fragrant
suffering screaming until your mouth fills with petals and
your nostrils shoot out thorny stems and a bulb sprouting
your eyes Leaving you nothing but a patch of flowers on the
ground swarming with butterflies are you done?
Yes, no, I've never seen that Tell me that's sprouting story
and Uh, get me out of here.
Get me out of here.
How many times do I have to say I'm sorry?
I do not care if you're sorry.
I want to know if you are loyal.
Look, I did what I had to do.
I did try the loyalty, so...
Unless I say it again.
Do I need to do it multiple times?
Look, I did what I had to do.
So what?
You have to try harder than that, Manuel.
A man's loyalties decide his destiny.
Okay, we'll try it again.
My loyalty is still to the DoD, believe it or not.
Tita!
Good boy.
You just keep up that spirit, and I'm sure you'll get out of
here soon enough.
What else do I have?
My cards.
My Robert Frost.
You just break the window with this.
Honestly, that would solve so much...
if we just kept breaking stuff, you know?
I am you years ago.
Hinto for me, Tom.
No, not yet.
I don't see anyone out there.
Doesn't open.
See if there's anything else in here besides this.
Whatever this is.
What was this?
It looks like it dispenses something called Philodent.
What the heck is Philodent?
Use it?
Oh Ick it came out like soft-serve ice cream but judging by
the smell I think it's auto body filler
Ick Fills a dent auto body filler.
I mean forbidden ice cream, right?
Well, where'd you pull that from buddy?
Oh, we dropped it
We're gonna fill him in.
No, come on!
Okay, hold on.
I'm gonna try one- oh wait, I'm gonna try one more time.
Hey guard!
Hello!
How's my little count of Monte Cristo?
Ready for walkies.
Please?
Please, please!
cramped ready for walkies are you ready to reveal your
loyalties my loyalty still to the DoD believe it or not good
boy we have to just keep do something that proves our
loyalty get out of here soon enough we have to do something
that proves our loyalty what what did I say are you guys got
saying mint why what did I say
We were closer to the...
Wait, what?
Oh, did I just, like, pick the wrong options?
Hey, guard!
How's my little count of Monte Cristo?
Loyalty to who, though?
Well, I thought that if I faked being loyal to the company,
he would let me out.
actually do that but look you got to open the door for me
amigo are you ready to reveal your loyalties the DoD runs a
crooked game and I intend to prove it I've heard you make
threats and anger before my question is would you really
want to hurt the DoD yeah I'm gonna blow the lid off this
place Young man, you are an enemy of the Department of
Death.
Yeah!
Oh!
Welcome to the club.
Oh, he likes me.
Salvador Limones, your guest.
Where are you taking me?
To the headquarters of the LSA.
LSA?
The Lost Souls Alliance.
We're a small group, Manuel.
We're always looking for new soldiers.
To do what exactly?
We need help in our intelligence.
You know Eva, of course.
Manny?
I was once a reaper like yourself, Manuel.
But I uncovered a web of corruption in our beloved
Department of Death.
I have reason to believe that the Bureau of Acquisitions is
cheating the very souls it was chartered to serve.
I think someone is robbing these poor, naive souls of the
rightful destinies, leaving them no option, but to march on
a treacherous trail of tears, unprotected and alone, like
babies, Manuel.
like babies babies what's your evidence that's where you
come in manuel or should i call you agent calavera wow i'm
not looking to join any military organization sal i just
want my job back so i can work off my time and get out of
this dump well you won't even be able to get out of this
city without my help which means of course you won't be able
to find that woman and you'll never get your job back when
you're ready to join yeah the lady we let go all right come
talk We might be of some use to each other.
Hmm.
Eva, what are you doing here?
So you're not really a secretary.
I'm a spy, Manny.
Well, that's the last time we use that template, you see.
Wait, an Eva?
Wow, an Eva that's a spy?
No.
What?
Wait, that's like so crazy.
no way no way this game came out in 1998 right
any messages for me shut up any messages for me yes join or
die but I'm already again they're going to sprout me does
Koppala ever want Doesn't Kapal wonder where you are?
Don and Domino are both locked up in Don's office with some
big wig from downtown, some fatty in a fez.
Oh.
Come on.
Who is the fat man?
Fat man!
And how does he fit into this sinister puzzle?
Everything is metal gear!
What are you working on?
What are you working on there?
I'm trying to get this radio working so we can use it in the
field.
But it looks pretty hopeless.
Salvador's right.
We need good old-fashioned homing pigeons to communicate
with our field agents.
field agents no it's just sal and me right now but someday
manny someday wait it's literally the smallest team ever
wait how long have you been a spy how long have you been a
spy salvedo recruited me about a year ago i couldn't resist
him he's just so noble they're gonna sprout me aba you gotta
get me out of town set up the codex you can't leave manny we
need access to the dod computer network if we're ever gonna
find that with going on and we can't access without a
salesman like you the computer IDs you when you log on how
does it do that fingerprints I don't have any your teeth
manny haven't you ever noticed your computer scanning your
teeth when you log on I thought that was just a power search
we need your teeth manny we can't let you go sorry so you
won't help me out of here sorry I'll help you out but not
your teeth think it over receive a message from Eva
loyalties and Eva and fat man never heard of that before
right so i want to look at this bed i don't get it nor do i
manuel the birds the birds are fake shut up no the birds are
spying on us too i put on a hand shadow show but the mood
just doesn't feel right i want to read i don't get it this
computer shut off we salvage that unit when the company
threw it away but we have yet to get it working when we do
we'll need you to get us into the system i'll be long gone
before then we'll see manuel Manuel it's a slide projector
it's going too fast I can't read it Manuel I was looking at
that oh what's in here where does this go to a secret tunnel
out of the city what it opens for members of the LSA only oh
okay you program it like that okay sure it won't budge it
opens for members of the LSA only Yeah, I heard you the
first time.
I heard you the first time.
Let's talk to Mickey's secret to one.
Do you know something, I don't know?
Have you ever wondered why your clients, even your best
clients, never seemed to qualify for the packages you know
they deserve?
Yes.
My last client in particular, Michi.
Well, they all did qualify, Manoli.
Especially her.
But somehow, somebody with access to the files has stolen
their just rewards.
Their sweet hereafters.
Their tickets on the number nine?
Precisamente, amen.
That was right.
What would they do with the tickets?
A ticket on the number nine is like a leaf of gold, Manuel.
Especially to one who has died with a less than perfect
record.
Someone is profiting here from those that would buy their
way into heaven.
You can't, dude, you can't, is that why I'm stuck here?
What a second?
Wait, what if my skelly was on the low totem?
Was on the low part of the pole?
And he couldn't...
I'm stuck in the purgatory because it was rigged from the
start.
Oh, man.
Minto got Fandangoed.
But money is not important here, right?
Money's not important here.
We all just want out you want to get out manuel and so do I
someday But for some people this world is all there is they
have decided to seek pleasure and happiness here in the
eighth underworld And for that you need money.
They created their own kind of money, right?
Oh my god, no No What do you want from me?
What do you want from me?
I'm going to build an underground army of souls to fight
Just as I have seen in El Marro, communication will become
vital as a lost souls alliance spreads out.
We'll need messengers we can trust.
You want me to be your messenger?
No, Manuel.
Our numbers are small and our agents are too valuable to
risk that sort of work.
History shows only one messenger to be of use to a cause
like ours.
Carry your pigeons.
Pigeon.
Back to the OL mines you go.
No!
I don't need the number nine.
I'm actually though.
I'm pretty curious what the train looks like if I grab some
pigeons off the roof will you let me go?
No, I need to raise them from birth agent Calavera.
I need you to bring me their eggs Oh, so there are real
birds we put their skelly birds they lay eggs you're keeping
me here because you need the eggs Why are you still here
Calavera go get me an air force before it hatches now.
That's all the briefing you need soldier Viva la revolution
Viva la revolution
Have you thought about using messages tied to balloons?
I can get you plenty of balloons.
Dijons, Manuel.
Bring me the eggs.
Well, okay.
Viva la revolution.
Vic boss.
Wait, this door is open.
Is that supposed to be like that?
Or...
We don't care.
I don't think I ever noticed the door.
I'm just a dummy.
I'm not observant at all.
Oh, save.
I could save.
Thank you.
Glottis?
Where are you?
Glottis.
Hey, what did they do with Glottis?
Oh, this is Glottis' house!
That's where I was.
I didn't even notice because we got...
No.
No!
It took GLaDOS!
GLaDOS!
I didn't mean to...
I didn't mean to hurt you!
Bring him back.
Alright, well I guess we're gonna be climbing up this thing
again.
There we go, what a thrill
Oh, the other rope is gone.
Hey, where did it go?
I'm gonna go peep.
I'm peeping.
What are you doing in there, huh?
The drapes are drawn.
Dom and Don must still be in there.
The drapes are drawn and Dom and Don must be in there.
No use for it.
Not picking that up.
Come on.
Come on, man.
I bet they're Kiesin.
We can't knock.
Tom's office is empty.
Uh-huh.
There's nobody in Domino's office.
Yeah.
La la la.
Open this up now.
What the?
What is it?
like a glowing hunk of coral glowing hunk of coral what is
it wait what is it what the heck is this congratulations
domino on your new job hector oh wait it looks like a
grappling thing right that we can use for uh for the rope
but there was no rope oh wait hold on wait wait wait wait I
didn't shut the drawer I'm kind of scared
Rope is still there on the other side Oh is it now?
Okay Maybe it's... Oh it's... Yeah I see it My arm is kind
of blocking it But oh yeah it is still there Okay cool Minto
cooking Maybe I understand how These games work sometimes
Maybe I understand how Point and Clicks get across now
sometimes all right combine that
i wonder if that's how domino meant it to be used oh
here we go nice
nice all right i will save real quick though let's go get
some eggs baby
You do need more things from Domino's office, though.
Oh, we do?
Should I go back?
Oh, it's like a cutscene though.
How do they lay the eggs?
I did want to go back and like get a
Shut his window I don't like the looks of those pigeons.
What's wrong with them?
Shoot I don't have a net or a desire to have a pigeon What
if I blow them out of the way with Robert Frost?
That's not on fire.
Oh, come on.
Come on, we're trying to shoot some pigeons.
This is the way to do it, no?
Come on.
It doesn't matter if it's not on fire or not.
I'm sorry, pigeons.
This is gonna hurt me more than it's gonna hurt you.
Wait.
No.
It's a miracle of afterlife.
Oh, okay.
Fearless little smug squabs.
Ah!
Oh, they started coming after me.
This ought to scare them.
You don't know that skeletons produced.
asexually that's crazy knowledge how did you know that what
if I what if I beat them in blackjack deck of cars just
wouldn't help there come on Robert Frost I choose you run
you pigeons it's Robert Frost got an achievement we're using
Robert Frost to intimidate the pigeons.
I might be way too attuned with this game.
Wait, this is a dog.
They'll be scared of it.
They might not know how much scarier a dingo is than a
regular dog.
Never mind.
They've lost all their instincts.
Dang it.
Never...
It's Robert Frost!
I've tried everything, though.
Let's see.
Let's see if there's...
What's this?
I prefer to eat out of clean dishes that aren't nailed to
the roof.
It's part of the roof.
Why?
So what does that matter?
The pigeons obviously like this dish vent.
Oh, maybe I can put food in it.
Maybe he has some food in his office.
I could just run at them.
I don't quite understand.
They come at me.
Oh!
No, no, not for me.
For the pigeons.
Not for me.
Poor one out.
Wait, the sand in here?
Hold on.
wait usually right no oh come on come on it's attached
pretty well but cut it off I don't know no what a jock dang
it keep
punching it oh
what is this it's Ew!
Ugh, Domino had this in his mouth.
Why do I want that?
Use it on me?
It's meant for mouths.
Wait, wait a second.
I don't remember what I think, this one.
Can I log into his PC with his mouth?
because of the teeth recognition or whatever.
It's meant for mouths.
So maybe I gotta get, maybe it has like his mouth shape or
something.
But still, this doesn't really help me with my pigeon
dilemma.
It's meant for mouths.
No, no, I tried to shut the door.
My bad.
Or shut the window.
Now there's three of them.
What if we...
Hold on.
We can make a mold.
With the foam, maybe?
Yay!
If we did that...
We could get into his computer, but I still don't, I still
don't know how that helps me with the, you know, with, uh,
with the pigeons, but.
I'm not going in there.
They still think I'm locked up.
Hopefully.
Oh, that's right.
Uh, please.
Eva.
Open up.
Agent Calavera here.
Oh, we definitely didn't look around here.
Just make sure nobody was tracking us.
Why don't you help me out?
I need your teeth, remember?
I have his teeth.
What's that?
Domino's mouthpiece.
Didn't get a dental impression off of it.
No, the plastic's so hard he didn't leave a mark.
Oh.
No.
That's it?
No, I don't believe you.
We're just, we're just gonna...
We're just gonna...
Wait, what about the dead thing that was in, um, Glottis'
shack too, since we can't go inside?
I can't believe it!
It must be useful if they let you take it.
That's what I'm saying!
Oh, you think he's got it some fear?
seed in here?
Wait, hold on.
But also...
Oh, oopsie.
There.
Yeah.
Oh!
Fill a dent.
Good for dentures.
Oh!
Yeah, baby!
You got any seed in your room?
What's in here?
it's locked locked what's this
who's afraid of a little rusty water that don't sound good
did any water even come out of that only just rust air now
if i bring this the teeth back maybe she'll be happy with me
and give me a big old smooch open up please agent calavera
here agent manny call me manny that's what everyone called
only rest
wham bam take a look at this ma'am this mouthpiece is full
of fill a dent
Take a look at this.
You hear that, Zach?
Ooh, what is that?
Custard?
Try it.
No, thanks.
I'm watching my figure.
Oh.
Is that it?
Uh.
Do you want to see the teeth?
I'm not sure what to make of that.
Why don't you show it to my intelligence officer?
How do I harden?
Okay.
Do the pigeons want to eat the philodent?
Well, I'm sure I probably have to bring his mouthpiece.
I don't want to make an impression of that.
Oh, wait.
What if he wears it?
Or I wear it.
Wow, that made a perfect impression of my teeth.
And quite a chalky aftertaste, too.
Well, that's what I was...
Wear it.
Got something here that might interest you.
But I'm gonna wear it.
I solved it.
My teeth.
Manny, this looks like a perfect impression of your teeth.
She did want my teeth after.
She did say so.
And get into the computer system that way.
Good work, soldier.
Yep, you're welcome.
Uh, do you have any chicken feed?
Have you thought about using messages tied to balloons?
I can get you plenty of balloons.
Pigeons, Manuel.
Bring me their eggs.
Well, okay.
Yeah, that was a really juicy bite.
We still have taste.
Somehow.
He said it tasted chalky.
Wait, there was bread over next to here, next to him.
I'm just gonna yoyink this.
Since I really didn't get to celebrate the festival this
year, I think I'm entitled to a little pan de muertos.
Yes!
Okay, bye!
Bread is terrible for birds, but what about skelly birds?
They don't have digestion systems or anything.
they need skeleton bread i'm just gonna kill the bread
really glad they don't hear me like huffing and puffing out
here all right eat up birds
what a thrill
Why am I walking so slowly?
Why am I in a cutscene?
Okay.
This is a crazy huge city.
Not today.
Not Robert Frost.
The bread of the dead.
The bread of the dead!
There you go!
Eat up!
Whoa!
How am I doing that?
fingers are are like a cheese grater.
Yeah.
Watch it.
Get them off me.
Yeah, go eat your bread.
What?
That was it.
Shoot.
Oh, no.
Well, hold on.
I'm wondering if I have to, like, put down the bread and
then get my scythe out and, like, swing, swing, swing,
swing, and then run over there.
There's always one more step than you think.
I'm learning that.
I don't want to ruin the solution.
Good, you shouldn't.
Let me, let me, let me think a little.
Let me.
I fed the answers.
I just take a little more bread to honor the dead.
Yes.
And one more even.
I just take a little more bread to honor the dead.
Just in case I mess up.
And how about one more for the road?
I just take a little more bread to honor the dead.
Yes.
I'm car maxing.
I didn't get my cat.
My kid wants another balloon animal.
Geez, what now?
A cat.
Okay.
No problem.
Meow.
Oh, it's so cute.
That's good.
It's good.
Thank you.
Do you think the birds are afraid of the cat?
Look at these.
They're so fun.
Meow.
I want to be for real.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Forever, meow.
Here's a little bread to honor the dead!
Cyber soldier, thank you.
It's the doncella mint of fantasma.
Dios meal.
Bread?
There you go.
Maybe you eat the bread and then the birds eat you and then
you'll all be connected.
But what if?
What if the bread is inside me?
What a thrill.
Forever bread.
I want to be forever bread.
Oh.
Back off, birds.
Dang it.
Wait, I had it, though.
See, maybe...
Oh, you're so right.
You are so right.
three breads in here one two cat it's a squeaky little kitty
kitty hmm they don't look scared i think they're actually
laughing at me i think they're making that up i
prefer to eat out of clean dishes that aren't nailed to the
roof
It didn't let me do any other action, right?
Hold on
Am I crazy?
Sick remix get away from me bird.
I get away from me bird.
I get away from me bird Bird bird bird.
Bird bird bird bird
Maybe that will scare them.
Can I take it back?
Robert Frost.
Robert Frost!
oh seven oh seven yeah beat it you lousy little ledge
pickers oh seven for robber frost I thought he was gonna be
endgame I'm not even kidding you you must come with me young
ones for I am the green Reaper I'm just gonna pocket all of
them man are those pigeons gonna be ticked Man, are those
pigeons going to be kicked?
Robert Frost!
No, it's okay.
It was meant to be.
That was so sad.
That was a really silly puzzle though.
That one was pretty silly.
That one was pretty like, okay, seriously.
Aging calavera and two guests.
Just waving that around.
The cojones.
Hello, here's your eggs.
I love when Minto's celebrating and Tuma's getting fuzzy.
Excellent, Manuel.
With ease, I can breed an entire army of winged messengers.
Our revolution can spread now across the land carried on the
shimmering wings of justice.
thanks to you agent Calavera you are a friend of the
revolution agent Calavera yeah now let me be of service to
you yes please you must go to the town of Rubacaba my friend
if you want to find your lost soul how do you know where she
is I don't but everyone who wants to get to the ninth
underworld must cross the Sea of Lament and therefore must
go to Rubacaba to get passage on a ship as long as you get
there before she does you'll find her but it may be quite a
wait i'll wait as long as it takes manuel are you up in love
with her love love is for the living cell i'm only after her
for one reason set things right she's my ticket out of here
oh
or that you know that was some tunnel i'm all the way to the
edge of the picture forest yeah wow whoa okay guys we can't
save over this one in case we ever want to go back and save
robert frost you understand slot one is off limits okay
my buddy
god is my friend why are you crying Maddie?
Oh, Maddie, they fired me!
Whoa!
Me too, buddy.
You don't understand, Maddie.
I was created just to do that job.
It's the only thing that makes me happy.
It's like they reached into my chest and pulled out my heart
and threw it into the woods too.
One.
me up he's very oh glottis what have you done glottis oh my
god wait wait what ew ew don't touch glottis's heart he's
it's too pure it'll melt you oh he's just asleep glottis is
also a beat to his five seconds today glottis also reminds
me of one of the little demon guys from uh Hercules.
Like the Disney movie?
You know what I'm talking about?
The red guy?
Oh, I can't leave.
Hmm.
Ew.
Oh, what a cinematic framing.
Ooh, ick.
Shoot.
Yeah, the minions.
Yeah, pain and panic.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Are you gonna get me?
Are you gonna try and get me?
I guess I could always use a spare.
Oh, okay.
Wait, can I use that to like get it out of the web?
Soup's on.
Oh.
They don't seem very interested in that bone I put in there.
Oh, I gotta get them interested in something.
Wait, if I try to grab it, what happens?
It's stuck in there good.
Okay.
All right, take that.
What about...
We could cut it out with the side.
Wait, I don't even have my balloons anymore!
All... Robert Frost would have been lost to us.
Wait.
He would have...
We would have lost him anyway.
New outfit, new inventory.
It must be...
No more demon heart to eat.
Aw, poor guy.
they're gonna starve they're gonna starve no I'm gonna
starve I
need you to get this a little faster so we okay oh my god
shut up please oh I hate the sound of
snoring heart heart is good be good to heart don't tear out
heart is good Strong, beating good heart.
Hey, is that my car?
Hey, do-do-do-do-do.
Mr. Lamont's, I assure you the missing woman will be found.
I will personally track her down myself.
Just like you personally picked her up from the land of the
living.
That was my intention, but Agent Calavera somehow got to her
first.
We gave you the fastest car, Domino.
We gave you all the best clients.
You had all the advantages.
So how was this Calavera able to sneak in there and eat your
lunch?
Oh, now, Hector, you can't get too mad at Domino.
That wasn't his fault.
Oh, I can, Don.
You should know I can get too mad.
But not at Domino.
After all, he wasn't in charge of this operation.
Fat man.
Not until now.
Hector!
He's not fat.
He's just big boned!
Oh!
He's getting sprouted!
Marigolds.
For some reason, I was expecting Culips.
Well, maybe Mr. Calavera ain't over no.
Why don't you personally go down to the basement and escort
him up here?
The sooner he's sprouted and we can get back to business,
the better.
Wanna go for a ride?
I thought you'd never ask!
Holy cow!
They're trying to sprout me.
Oh, sorry.
Three point, wait, am I driving this thing?
Wait, hold on.
Oh, no, not load, uh.
Man, this is a low-riding street rod, not a four by four.
My bad.
We don't have the clearance for that kind of road.
Ah, back it up.
Okay.
Now what do we have here?
What the heck is this thing?
What sort of unholy Christmas tree farm is this?
What is this thing?
Gladys?
Manning, check out this wheelbarrow, will ya?
With a couple of ATV nubby tires on the back and a
two-stroke Lormo engine.
Not this puzzle?
Uh-oh.
It's so loud and annoying.
I'm just gonna turn it off.
Ugh.
Ooh, careful, Manny!
With the harmonic balance it turned off, those pumps are
turned off.
might shake that tree apart oh but but oh if we shook the
tree down those pumps would dislodge and I could make
high-lift shocks out of them for the own wagon hold on I'm
going to unbalance that wheel with some of these weights
shake it down for sure sure what I didn't have to do
anything okay just give me Give me a second to balance these
doggies.
Yep.
It's unbalanced.
Hey, Manny, what are you doing?
Outside of the entertainment value, that didn't do what I
had hoped.
Aw, man, is it not balancing up?
What are you doing?
Oh, just get back up there.
Vlad has he got this.
That was a dirty trick, Manny.
He's up, yeah.
There's an accident.
I bumped the switch with my elbow.
Oh, okay.
Ha.
Oh, I guess it wasn't gonna work then, huh?
Oh, I gotta get out of here.
Come on, come on.
Let's go take the other road.
There's too many noises.
Oh my god, we have to wait for him to...
Glottis, please.
Everybody is just taking their sweet old time!
Okay.
Alright, we got this.
Oh, I'm gonna do a sick donut in here.
Yeah, yeah, I was definitely overstimulated in there.
But not here!
Donut!
Oh yeah!
Wait, is this a hole?
Oh, is this a...
How do we know where we need to...
Wait, this is a hole too.
What about this one?
I mean, I think they're all holes, but...
Alright, alright.
Ew!
This is the hardest puzzle in the game?
No kidding.
I'm...
The hard part is driving this dang thing through it.
How am I supposed to know?
Did I go through this one?
How am I supposed to know which one to go through?
Like, it's a wake-scoop.
How do I know when I've gone to a correct location?
Or a correct...
My music is so fun.
Yep, um...
I think I need to restart if I've done anything at all.
I'm not quite sure.
Oh.
Okay, here we go.
Should try the other screen first.
You think so?
Okay.
Alrighty, I'll try this one first.
Oh.
Do these wheels do anything?
Oh, no, no.
Goddess, what are they doing to that tree?
Oh, city boy.
You work all day in a 60-story skyscraper, but didn't you
ever wonder what it was made of?
The marrow of these trees.
They suck it out.
It's like cement.
What?
Is that what the town's called El Morrow?
I never thought of that.
Oh.
What?
Oh, no!
What do you say?
Mip.
No!
I
thought...
Mip.
We silenced him.
Oh, wait.
I see that.
Okay, hold on.
Wait, I'm trying to get it.
There we go.
Okay, I've stopped two of them.
No, I've stopped one of them.
Oh dang it!
Oh my god.
Okay, I stopped it.
Put the wheelbarrow down.
Now...
He's just walking really slowly.
It's just gonna...
What is he gonna do?
I'd climb it myself, but I don't want to take all the fun
away from Glottis.
Okay, Glottis.
Wait.
place gives me the creeps.
I'm ready to go when you are.
Can we have Gladys climbing again?
Oh wait, maybe I stop it.
That'll do it.
Hey, while you have that off, let me try moving those
weights around some more.
Oh.
Oh, monkey this is this time, Calavera.
Of course, of course.
Maybe?
That was a dirty trick.
Wasn't me, though.
Oh, the kids.
Oh, okay.
I thought maybe putting it on this would like...
Wait, what's that sound?
Something didn't like that.
What?
They have to sink.
Oh.
Oh, I get it.
Ah!
Oh no.
I wanna drive this thing all over the forest.
You will once I get that two stroke in there.
Okay, we make them all sync with...
Dang it.
I didn't... that was the only one that was synced with the
first one.
Oh my gosh, this is tricky.
Oh, I got it, I got it, okay.
Cool.
Thank you for the hint on getting them synced.
Dang it.
Yay!
It did do a big wobble when the first, when the other two
were synced, didn't it?
Dang it.
Ah.
Wait, I'm I'm getting the timing off.
There we go.
Hey, while you have that off, let me try moving those
weights around some more.
Nice.
Nice and stable.
Oh.
Wait, guys, I think my game is...
That should do it.
Still not enough.
And maybe if I moved them around a little.
I couldn't tell if he was going to do that.
Hey, while you have that off, let me try moving those
weights around some more.
Okay.
I broke him.
Okay, we're fine now, maybe.
Now.
Oh.
Wait.
go okay but this should be it well come on this is it yeah I
got the part oh it's a little ears are too cute from now on
we saw like eagles like eagles on
eagles above the clouds yeah baby I was getting concerned
that our transportation wasn't ostentatious enough get in or
are you afraid of heights glottis is so funny yippee so now
we can go over the rocks let's save real quick I guess we
were gonna lose...
We were gonna lose him anyway, so...
No, I can't give it up yet.
Welcome to a Mambusha Day, or welcome back, Thaw!
Thank you so much!
Take it, take it, take it, take it.
Oh.
Hey!
There he goes.
Glottis.
He's just...
He's keeping himself.
Occupied.
He's so cute.
Now what is this?
Manny!
What are you doing?
Don't you know what's on the other side of that gate?
Yeah, the way out of the forest.
Demon beavers, Manny?
Demon beavers!
They'll make you into a dam!
Relax, Chippewa.
I'm not made of wood.
But Manny!
They don't use wood.
Oh my god, it's literal demon beavers.
Oh no!
Oh my god!
Oh!
Aye!
Deeb!
That's not on fire.
No, just...
Aye!
Oh, dang it.
That's awkward.
There it is.
Why didn't she use it?
Man, eh?
What is he doing?
What are you doing?
No, no, don't talk.
Oh my god!
The one thing that's on fire, exactly.
We finally have something on fire and he doesn't want to
spray it.
Do I have to press the button?
Oh, that guy just died.
Oh shoot!
Use it!
We were so close.
Oh, I hate the controls.
Run, run, run.
Run.
That road leads out of the forest, I'm sure.
But I don't think I'd get rid of...
That road leads...
Oh my god!
Well, do I go get GLaDOS then?
What do you want me to do?
What?
GLaDOS, come on.
that's not on fire oh my god
monsters no way manny oh those flaming bone beavers are mean
they bite they claw and if one of them wrapped around my
drive shift i'd be picking flaming hunks of fur out of my
u-joint for months i'm not going down there until you get
rid of them okay oh oh wait he just totally turned us around
no come on the other puzzle though.
I haven't done that one yet.
He wants them gone.
The beavers yelling at me.
Wait, they like bones, right?
So what if I throw it...
I'd like to save bones for special occasions.
No, hold on.
Look to the left.
Oh, what is this?
I didn't even realize this was a path.
What is this?
It's just telling me to click here for some reason.
No, I don't think I could swim a single stroke in that tar.
This river seems to be made of tar, but those beavers just
seem to cut through it like water.
Yeah.
I tried the bone.
I tried again.
Maybe I was clicking the wrong spot.
Whip it out.
Is he going in there?
Oh, they're all going in there.
Wait, I'm stuck?
Hmm.
I think...
Where did I get that bone from?
I think I need a couple, no?
Oh, I got it from the spiders.
Let's get a couple.
Let's get four.
of them maybe as they jump in i spray them but they jumped
in anyway you know wait was it this way i ain't driving back
to town manny uh wait was it this way this way
no way how am i supposed to get more boards Uh, hmm.
Oh my god.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, fuck.
Well, we also gotta complete this part, too, no?
So, let me see.
I still don't know.
I want a hint for this part.
This puzzle isn't fair.
You need something else on another screen for this.
Oh, you can't brute force.
force it.
Oh, okay.
I thought that maybe me getting the tire upgrade would be
enough.
Or, you know, the car upgrade.
Seems like not.
Okay.
Thank you, everybody.
For your right inside.
I wonder where you could get more boas.
There's the whole bone pile, but like...
Oh, wait.
It'll let me grab from here.
Yoink.
And Storv.
And Yoink.
So you're gonna come after me?
No, they don't care.
Yoink.
And Storv.
Okay.
Very good.
so then I throw throw me a bone here
and then wait wait wait don't do it yet select
is he gonna jump too
okay now we throw another bone Throw me a bone.
Okay, so it was right.
Yippee!
Alright.
And then...
Select.
Yeah!
Wow!
Is
that another bone?
Okay!
Again, again!
I thought there were four of them.
Just in case, just in case I will throw one more.
Our final bone.
Oh, oh, oh.
Okay, that was it.
There were definitely four of them.
But it only, I guess it only counted the ones on the bridge.
Okay!
Let's go!
Alright, let's go!
good come on glass no what are you doing
okay the beast no you guys we would have lost robert frost
anyway it's fine manny look at that badass gate i can't
drive through that we have to find the key the key yeah we
we would have lost robert frost anyway so it's okay we lost
all of our balloon animals sadly road leads out of the
forest, I'm sure.
But I don't think I'd get very far on foot.
Plus, how could I leave without Gladys?
What does a he-hole-le-mean?
You have to find a key.
Is it amongst the bones?
Is this the key?
I couldn't take that off with my bare hands.
What about my bare scythe?
Run.
I don't want to mess up my blade.
Oh my god.
Let's search maybe their key.
What if it's like my skelly finger?
What if it's like we can use like a little skeleton hand to,
you know, I guess it's not really a hand.
Dang.
Oh my god.
A skeleton key.
Yeah, yeah, exactly, exactly.
This looks like a different spot, ish, maybe.
Never mind.
I'd like to save bones for special occasion.
I'm just going to be hoarding all these bones.
Uh.
I'm scanning.
Every time I search one of these, it takes me the same spot.
Um.
Yeah, let's investigate the gate some more.
It's so loud!
It won't let me back in there anymore, so...
I have
so few things.
These two keep making me want to like think that they're
like X marks the spot, you know what I mean?
I'll just drop this one.
I'm carrying around too many of those already.
Guys, I will be right back.
I actually have to use the little ghosty's room.
So, maybe in the woods.
I don't know.
I have to use the little ghosty's room.
So I'll be right back.
Meow.
Wait.
I want to play.
Grab a more tea too!
One second.
One second!
I didn't mute.
Oopsie.
Okay.
I...
What if I had left you on that screen?
With...
Wait, what's happening?
Where are you going?
Oh, okay, you're just walking.
To be funny.
Let's go talk to him.
I wish I could, actually.
I'm thinking the next project should be wings.
He's two in the zone.
He's literally...
He's so busy.
I left my tow truck back in my other suit.
I don't know.
He says, I can't lift this with my bare hands.
I couldn't take that off with my bare hands.
And then with the bone, it didn't work.
It didn't work with the bone, right?
No place for a bone there.
At least you wouldn't have ever left us on the
bink-bink-bunk machine screen, right?
Never.
It's been a while, but I think you need something in another
spot.
Oh, wait.
No place for a bone there.
Put it away.
Let's get out of here.
Let me go, please.
Leave.
The only thing I can think of is maybe...
Tank controls.
I'm playing tank controls.
Did we actually look in this rubble pile for anything else?
Wait, what is here?
It's not letting me- There's no door on this trailer.
I think it's just a big generator.
No trailer hitch on the bone wagon.
Yeah, I won't let us, like, go here.
So...
I'm... I'm a little lost, I think.
Oh, oh, gosh, why does it do that?
And this one we can't do yet, right?
There's something you can find here.
No, I am asking for hints at this point.
It's okay.
I'm a little stuck.
Hints are fine.
Thank you, though.
I appreciate you trying to look out.
I'm bread hot.
Can I get off?
Oh, I can get off the car, can't I?
like the only thing that I can take I didn't even think that
I could get off the car here no way oh my gosh that's why I
couldn't get to the spider area I'm just gonna yank that is
it gonna point to the place that like the hole right now
Wait, where are we going?
I'm not carrying this thing any farther if it's going to
keep pointing the other way like that.
It's demoralizing.
Yeah, it keeps pointing to the hole that I need to go to, I
think.
Oh my god.
Can I walk back to the car?
Okay, there we go.
Can I do this puzzle without the car?
to see this.
How am I supposed to see this?
Yes.
This one?
Puzzle for ants!
Am I doing this right?
Did it just...
Wait, what?
I think you do need the bone wagon.
You think so.
Okay.
This one?
I can't see it!
Wait, can you do the look on it?
Yeah, that's a good idea.
That's a good idea.
Well, it's pointing somewhere.
It looks like this one.
It's so tiny.
But also, it's a different one than when I...
Just...
Pointed I?
It was like pointing at somewhere up there before.
I think.
I don't know anymore.
Can you attach the sign to the wagon?
I wish.
This one?
I don't know how many times I need to do that.
Wait, it's different pointing than when I placed it in the
middle.
Ignore the holes, just keep moving the sign.
Oh, really?
Wait, what?
Huh?
What do you...
Is there, like, something that is not that the whole...
I'm gonna...
I hope I will understand.
So it's something...
It was pointing this way.
Okay, and now it's pointing down.
So it's something like over here.
Okay.
So like right over here.
Oh!
We got something!
What the hell?
Is that the- there's the key!
It's not gonna be so easy though, right?
Save.
Oh, sorry, sorry, sorry.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
What the heck?
Hamburger chain in Japan.
Mason's West, welcome back.
Thank you!
Thank you guys for the help on that one.
a doozy it looks like some sort of warning sign they'll tear
you apart bone by bone and build with you a human throne
their bucktooth king will sit upon what once was you but now
is gone this key unlocks the gates of hell steady traveler
use it well uh yoink I don't think that's a wait can't pass
up an old creepy key uh okay wait what's this way
oh well would you look at that yeah i was talking about the
beavers right this outer gate is huge i'll need glottis to
open it glott oh man i don't know if i like this Hello,
hello, hello, we're in the occlusion.
Thank you so much for the pink.
Don't know, thank you.
But because you and I, Gladys, are friends.
Ah, many.
That road gets out of the forest, I'm sure.
But I don't think I'd get very far off.
He repeated that.
Yeah, I mean, though.
Hello, Jerry.
Welcome back.
Miss Coloma.
We're here to save you.
Lay off the racket, the whole town's asleep.
Are they?
Ha ha ha.
I'm going to get a load of my car.
We're going to be the talk of the town.
Hey.
You're right.
We're going to have to find a good place to hide that rotus.
Speaking of hiding, I wonder if Mitch is here already.
I'm going to go see what I can stir up.
Not a bad piece of real estate, actually.
It's got potential.
Wowie, wowie, powie.
Goodness.
Are you going to continue playing Min-to?
I think that I will actually call it for today, but I think
I'll play again tomorrow.
So, um, we can play more tomorrow.
Grim Fandango.
And this is a lot of fun.
I'm excited to play more.
So, it's a good stopping point.
Yeah, it's so awesome!
Oh my gosh.
I'm having a lot of fun, so you're at the very end of the
first quarter.
Perfect.
Perfect, perfect, perfect.
Did anyone get today's cannibalism timer?
There was none!
I would keep playing if I didn't have things that I need to
take care of, so...
Yeah, yeah.
Game is divided into four chapters.
I did see that.
Wait, so, will it say chapter two?
Because if it does, maybe I just play to chapter two.
Maybe.
Rest in glitch phase, thank you for the pop, get there!
You're almost to chapter two.
Maybe I should just play to chapter two then.
Sorry for anybody who left.
I will play to chapter two.
I did want to do, like, each stream a chapter, so...
I will do that.
Oh, hey, buddy.
Hot dishes.
Mr. Flores, I'm ready to take you now.
Manny Calavera.
Is that you?
Didn't you used to be taller?
I'm looking for...
Oh, I've...
Yeah, what are you doing here?
Well, if you must know...
It's about my wife.
I got word that she passed away, not like...
long after I and that she too was crossing the land of the
dead on foot it is said that all lost souls come to Rubakava
so I came here to wait for her you must very much love her
very much also yes this is true of course she also has all
of my money oh well how do you know your wife hasn't gone
ahead of you your wife hasn't gone ahead of you oh Manny if
she had arrived here first surely she would have waited for
me okay what does she look like yeah i'll help you find your
wife what did she look like oh here i got this from the dod
and made copies to hand out isn't she something she must
have been beautiful yeah now we got her um i'm here to
reclaim that walking stick i broke it over the head of some
hideous monsters in the forest oh come on man yeah do you
know i'm looking say this colomar well no one's come through
town by that name and you can take it from me i too i'm
looking for someone so i watch the comings and goings around
here very carefully okay okay do you know a good place to
stay in town what's your price range somewhere around the
high end of nothing then maybe young man it's time you
started thinking about a job a job no can you give me a job
here have any skills sales well then That does qualify you
for a certain position, but we only have one mop.
I'm sorry, Manuel.
I've got to get this place ready to open.
Right.
I'll let you know if I see your wife.
How many...
She'll be the one asking for her beloved Celso.
How many Skellies are asking for...
Or going to restaurants is my question.
Not the job application, right?
Was there...
Oh, I didn't see if there was...
Okay.
What's this?
Many skills.
Maybe I should place a personal land.
I tried it.
Believe me.
It attracts the wrong kind of women.
What kind?
Maybe I should place a personal land.
What's up there?
How do we get to there?
Oh, there's more.
Oh.
Ah!
you step around here stranger rubikab ain't the quaint
little port town she used to be well hell looks like there's
a new vessel in town well i have it how do you get that on a
script and like know what to say oh i'm shivering can i do
it twice i think i'll wait for the fog to clear
mostly stock with a few mods here and there so car guys am i
right i'm hearing our turbos
hey mr
improv maybe where yeah where there was this one
high-pitched wine it was making really grating noise you
know and i searched and searched but i couldn't find the
source of the noise until we pulled in here wasn't the
blower no it was man he's screaming I was gonna say it
wasn't us!
That's a good one.
Hey, Manny.
Doc Master Velasco here says he's got a place we can drive
Dr. Bonewagon for a while.
That's a crazy name.
We can't leave a beauty like this out in the fog or her
chrome will get pitted.
Pitted?
Did you hear that, Manny?
Are you folks gonna stay in Rubikava for a spell?
Sure.
Uh, yeah.
We're here looking for a woman named Mercedes Colomar.
I'm not too good with that.
names did you have any distinguishing marks tattoo not that
she showed me well like I said I'm as good with names as you
are with the form they're bonding look his face though I
might be here a while yeah any work is there any work in
this town well there's lots of work down at the docks but
it's all union work there's unions in the afterworld this is
too real
with all the mist.
Uh, when you've strode these docks as long as I have,
Pilgrim, you know where you are by the smell of the sea.
This voice acting in this game is too good.
By the sound of the lonely falling on.
Glottis, are you good?
By the icy touch of the cold, salty air.
Blink, blink if you're all right.
Manny, could I have an eye patch?
I know another character that Glottis reminds me of.
The sun in Bob's Burgers.
What's his name?
Uh...
Gene!
It reminds me of Gene!
Can I just ask, what is under the eye patch?
Because I know it's not an eye.
Oh, well, when I was alive, I had an eye patch like this.
This one's just for the Phantom Pain.
And my eye socket used to scream like a Banshee when the
trade winds blue.
That's another Metal Gear reference!
in the middle of a conversation how many times did Kojima
play this game
how many times Epsos Kojima played this game
how many okay well um i've always wanted one of those
jackets so true you sure a woman named Mercedes Colomar
never came through this town she might have i don't know i
told her the first time i'm no good with names where can i
go Gladys, you gotta hide that car.
In a minute, Manny, I'm talking to Mr. Darkmaster here.
Maybe the fog blew away.
I think I'll wait for the fog to clear before I try
exploring town again.
He's no good with names, yeah.
Hmm.
You think it's Skullface came here?
Wait, Skullface?
face it's too much it's too too many coincidences are you
sure i can't sleep in the back there's only room for one and
room for two with my wife i could pretend to be your wife
what do they need me to do rumor has it he played it for
nine years
oh wait we had the photo i forgot wait Wait, that's not our
girl though.
Wait, actually, what is this photo?
Is that her?
It's Celso's wife.
Actually, I don't think skin would help.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
What if we show it to him though?
Ever seen this woman?
Oh, if this is the woman you're looking for, take my advice.
Forget about her.
sailed out of here weeks ago and a cozy port side cabin
built for two and she wasn't alone how do you know how do
you know she sailed out of here i don't believe it that's a
tough break junior but you gotta face it here look at my
port log if you want it in writing six weeks ago take it for
two paid in full i cracked the champagne on the bar myself
hey manny we were in Hey, hey, okay.
Look, I know how you feel.
Uh-oh.
Once I lost a very special lady myself, I waved to her from
the docks as she sailed out of port, and I never saw her
again.
What was her name?
The SS Lamontia was her name, but don't make me talk about
her because I just can't do it.
Oh, he's crying.
Gosh, Manny, why would you do that?
Why would you do that to him?
Why would you make him, like, feel that way?
the boat boats man she probably was a butte
hey buddy how about in the attic that's the boss's office
you can sleep there when you're the boss do i have the log
on me did he give that to me he did okay great velasco's
logbook says selso's wife took a bunk with a hunk a bunk
with a hunk
sailed out of here two months ago with another man.
Okay.
It's all in there.
Oh, Manny, is there a greater constant in nature than the
treachery of women?
Forget about her, Celso.
Have you forgotten yours?
I'm going after her.
You take over my job here.
This mop at least will never let you down.
That compass in the handle will sure come in handy too.
Oh, the compass is in the handle!
You lion.
Year one, spend a year in the eighth underworld.
oh my god we made it but did we one year later completed
chapter one yay oh
oh we transformed we're the great katsby the great manny hey
boss you gonna come downstairs i got a customer asking for
you we know i don't like to mingle with We've transformed
this place.
Well, you may want to mingle with this one.
She sounds like your type.
Well, looks like a quiet night in old Rubicaba.
All right, now here is where we'll end it.
Dang!
One year later.
Look at this!
The port is old!
Wow, wow!
Seeing this in my algorithm recommendations after...
watching the back rooms is kind of tripping I hope I was as
handsome as the skeleton fella cross arc thank you so much
for the super chat hope you enjoyed the back rooms I want to
see it too it actually really shows how badly the DoD must
have been screwing Manny over right he was able to build
this like giant Empire restaurant business the guy knows
sales they were just really dang but this has been great so
far I will continue it tomorrow sorry I did say I was going
to end it earlier but I did want to end it at the end of
chapter 2 so this is a great place to end off we'll play
more tomorrow this is really fine thank you so much for for
Grim Fandango part 1 Otomito Otomito Otomito it's a nice
show thank you everybody thank you thank you bye bye bye bye
bye see you Have a good day, have a good night, have a good
time!
Oh, sorry.
Oh wait, oh wait, my mic is on!
I just apologize!
My bad.
I will
get to them.
Don't you worry.
Probably later this week though.